bonjour c'est d'être là
l'art numérique qu'est ce que c'est je
vais vous faire d'abord très bref
bref présentation d'un contexte
historique puisque l'art numérique
bénéficie un double mouvement d'intérêt
par les chercheurs les scientifiques
vers l'image et des artistes vers les
machines
19e siècle passionnés en siècle
découverte et d'automatisation de
capture d'image par le biais de
différents procédés notamment bien sûr
d'abord la photographie avec des
procédés qu'on avait déjà observé depuis
l'antiquité par le biais de sténopés et
de chambre noire et donc niépce puis
daguerre vont trouver les méthodes des
matériaux pour enregistrer les images
dans la foulée deuxième partie du 19e
siècle le cinématographe s'appuie sur
ses inventions les systématise et trouve
par le biais de la lanterne magique est
déjà présente au xviie siècle
comment projeter des images les
enregistrer les projeter un grand
inventeur qui était aussi un artiste
emile reynaud réunit le praxinoscope
donc un des beaux objets optique du dix
neuvième siècle où il y avait un
cylindre ou éventuellement été dessiné
des images et il réunit différentes
inventions bien sûr aussi et
l'électricité la lanterne magique et par
le biais d'un miroir il re projette ses
dessins réalisés sur des
cellophane enfin c'est pas leur terne
cellophane et vous voyez le public et de
l'autre côté l'image et découvre les
images en mouvement
20e siècle arrivé de l'électronique la
télévision les débuts de la télévision
miniaturisation concept très important
pour réduire la taille le poids le crew
des éléments et puis avec l'informatique
aussi bien sûr c'est sur plusieurs
siècles 1 pourrait remonter aussi au
xviie siècle avec pascal lapasse câline
toutes ces machines à calculer qui se
développe l'utilisation des cartes
perforées aussi on est à lyon avec le
domaine du textile et la mécanisation
des métiers à tisser qui arrive
progressivement bain au xxème siècle
avec bien sûr l'effort de guerre et la
miniaturisation la démocratisation et la
massification des utilisations de
l'ordinateur de l'informatique puisque
vous avez tous maintenant un ordinateur
dans vos poches et bien plus puissants
que ceux là
la société évolue deux révolutions
industrielles
bien sûr les artistes font partie la
société ils observent ces changements
société y commence à dessiner des
machines je vous ai mis deux grands
révolutionnaires on peut dire en art
picabien et de grands amis deux grands
rivaux ils vont être aussi deux grand
provocateur les sculpteurs
progressivement s'y intéressent aussi
construisent des images laszlo moholy
nagy je vous ai mis aussi les dates de
naissance les pays d'origine puisque
c'est aussi un grand melting-pot
l'europe la france l'allemagne
pour les échanges d'idées et n'en fait
moulinade qui est aussi enseignant obara
hausse et qui va continuer sa carrière
d'enseignant aux états unis et puis
dingli qui est alors c'est très
intéressant c'est parce qu'il est suisse
1 et suisses et des experts en horloge
et en mécanisme est gentille li va
s'amuser à faire des machines qui ne
servent à rien entre guillemets cas être
des machines poétique et qui parfois qui
même dessine des machines à destiner
voir des machines qui s'autodétruisent
l'art abstrait arrive l'arabe serait
d'abord lyrique avec kandinsky puis
progressivement le cubisme l'art
abstrait géométriques arrive un jouet
mais les deux grandes figures de l'art
abstrait géométriques malevitch mondrian
malevitch et là une espèce de
révélations boum ça lui tombe dans la
tête de faire de l'art abstrait par
contre mondrian ça va être sur plusieurs
décennies je vous encourage à aller voir
ces arbres parce qu'il a fait toute une
série de peintures d'après nature menti
on peut dire où on voit progressivement
la vision devenir de plus en plus
géométriques et c'est passionnant l'art
numérique définition et bien l'art
numérique c'est juste en inde hier de
faire de l'art avec du numérique on a
des ordinateurs on à l'informatique ben
voilà mais vous allez me répondre mais
qu'est ce que l'art si on ne sait pas ce
que c'est l'art il suffit pas d'utiliser
un ordinateur pour faire n'importe
quelle image on ne saura pas si c'est de
l'art ou 6 6 2 couches ont donc la
redéfinition alors pour vous faire bref
ce que je n'ai que 15 minutes ou presque
l'histoire de l'art montre
progressivement avec le 19ème et le
20ème siècle que ce qui compte en art ce
n'est pas tant ce qu'on représente mais
comment on leur présente la manière de
représenter ça veut dire jeux formels
changements formels création forme alors
part par là vous avez par exemple les
grands textes exemple de picasso qui est
un destructeur de forme un inventeur de
formes passionnant bien sûr ça met en
jeu de la technique bien sûr c'est un
enjeu de la créativité la sensibilité de
l'émotion mais surtout la grande avancée
du 20e siècle c'est le jeu avec les
formes et c'est la liberté par rapport
aux formes les artistes sont des gens
qui prennent énormément de liberté est
aussi en jouant à provoquer
alors l'ordinateur dans tout ça est ce
qui nous donne davantage de liberté pour
créer quelle sorte de liberté on peut
avoir l'ordinateur quels sont ses
propriétés à l'ordinateur ses qualités
aller plus vite toujours plus vite être
plus efficace
automatisé et aidera qu'est ce que ça
peut apporter en arrêt ce que d'une
certaine façon l'art numérique ce serait
de faire des choses toujours plus
complexe le jo plus rapide non bien sûr
on va voir quelques exemples
des pionniers bien sûr dans la
perspective de tingle y les sculpteurs
vont jouer à faire en même temps une
espèce d'art abstrait en mouvement mais
nicolas chauffeur qui nous vient de
hongrie qui va vivre une grande partie
de sa vie en france
il insère des capteurs c'est la première
ce qu'il suit sculpture cybernétique qui
réagit à son contexte vous voyez les
années 50
vera monard toujours vivante toujours
active presque centenaire qui commence
bien sûr à cette époque là dans les
années 50-60 c'est déjà larges et aux
métriques tels que j'ai montré avec
malevitch et mondrian
verra mona recommence l'art géométrique
par des séries autour du du quart et
qu'elle trouve passionnant et
l'ordinateur va lui permettre de
d'explorer autrement la forme elle
repose d'ailleurs d'avoir plus de
liberté avec cette machine d'avoir
d'autres idées et c'est intéressant moi
j'étais très stimulés quand j'ai
découvert son travail elle propose
naître du désordre 1% des hordes cnc
petit monde fred moore toujours active
toujours
créatif plus 80 ans
qui commence dans les années 70 une
passion autour du carré donc bien sûr
les formes géométriques ce sont des
éléments beaucoup plus facile à mettre
en visuel si on peut dire avec les
machines
aux etats unis ils ont bien sûr leur
propre pionnier que je connais moins en
tout cas mayron kruger est toujours
vivant qui a développé une interface
avec une caméra une observation de
l'image
lui par l'ordinateur et donc la
possibilité d'avoir un élément
artificielle que soit une image elle
même plan pictural ou un élément
organique enfin graphique qui va réagir
à l'image et puis au japon ils ont aussi
un très très grand pionnier qui est
passionnant il a que 70 ans est toujours
active toujours créatif maintenant il
fait davantage des sculptures parce
qu'aussi au niveau du marché de l'art
c'est quand même plus rentable il est
pionnier en terme d'animation 3d en
mélangeant des procédures fractales avec
der et racines donc un style de rendu de
l'image des réflexions sur la 1000
images et puis une technique qu'ils ont
beaucoup développé au japon les
métabolites donc une enveloppe autour de
ce fer qui permettent de faire des
formes très organiques alors et moi dans
tout ça donc gamine
rêveuse littéraire je désire être
artiste plutôt parce que sa vedette trop
dire pour moi en tout cas je m'imaginais
dans des couleurs ou des livres ma
famille considère que c'est pas très
sérieux de dire ce qui est qu'est ce que
ces artistes qui picole ils passent leur
temps à rêver tutorat
je fais un bac + 2 contrainte et forcée
en voulant plaire les parents mais en
déprimant énormément ma mère on entend
parler d'une section images de synthèse
à paris à je file à paris toute heureuse
de pouvoir esquiver les mathématiques et
puis en même temps je me mets
informatique mathématiques et art c'est
pas possible c'est pas possible et je me
dis mais bon bah écoute on va les voir
ainsi si c'est paradoxal de réunir des
machines de contrôle
et puis un désir d'expression de soi et
d'émotion il ya peut-être des choses à
trouver terra incognita
alors première
position c'est adopté là langage de
l'ordinateur parce que sinon on va faire
finalement quelque chose qui a déjà été
fait il faut prendre le langage de
l'autre si on peut dire et essayer de
comprendre et c'est de voir ce qui
pourrait sceller par contre j'ai pas
fais d'informatique donc moi je viens
éventuellement un peu des maths donc
première étape
le plus simple possible procédure simple
parce que je veux comprendre et en même
temps mon point de vue c'est que c'est
pas parce que c'est complexe que c'est
artistique deuxième démarche c'est qu'en
fait
je vais appeler mes amis les artistes
des peintres à la rescousse et je vais
chercher quelles sont leurs idées
comment ils ont fonctionné comment ils
ont inventé ou révolutionner la 1 donc
là vous voyez premières images 90 le
travail s'appelle un peu de peau ses
talents corps j'ai pas le temps de vous
montrer les animations choix d'une 3d
plate par provocation mais aussi bien
sûr par revendication d'une attitude
d'artistes ce qui compte c'est pas la
complexité formel c'est la surface et
l'ambiguïté si on peut dire du regard
dans une surface
je découvre aussi l'affichage filaire
des modèles tridimensionnels lorsque le
rendu n'est pas réalisée sur chaque
facette et j'adore ce filaire pour moi
ça évoque les toiles d'araignées toutes
sortes de choses et les textures une
fois prises dans l'image donc j'affiche
plusieurs fois les modèles
tridimensionnels
je le prends texture je leur ai à pic
sur mes surfaces j anime les surfaces et
ses textures
tridimensionnel sont passionnantes filet
parce qu'on peut trouer les surfaces
trouver les surfaces qu est très
difficile à faire en 3d faire de
l'imperfection et puis faire la matière
tous ces pixels sont étirées sont tordus
et ça apporte une espèce de matérialité
de tactilité à l'image qui mois pour moi
sont importantes en termes de plaisir
visuel
deuxième travail j'ai des amis qui m'ont
dit remettez images ça évoque la
peinture gestuelle là je m'inspire de la
peinture rituel je fais des tubes des
tubes
entortillé qu'à bosser sur lesquels
jurés applique les textures filaire
jeu cabos les formes c'est des tubes un
jeu les cabosses
là vous voyez aussi les sphères qui me
permette de cabosser les tubes et par
dessus je joue le jeu j'affiche
plusieurs strates d'image je commence à
se pratiquer fier l'espace alors que
d'habitude la 3d c'est un espace le
dédiant une perspective unique et ceara
travail suivant je met en mouvement ses
strates d'image le filaire les
différentes formes qui s'affiche je
développe une technique de l'art et
affichage enregistrement changement de
couleur du fond ray affichage etc bien
sûr à l'époque les ordinateurs sont
beaucoup moins rapide que maintenant
c'est une demi-heure par image une
seconde animation ses 24 images 12
heures de calcul donc vous voyez que
c'est toute une technique très
différente de celle qu'on a maintenant
et puis émerge alors si vous le voyez en
mouvement c'est du gros iman en fait un
saint mathias l'imperfection le la
matière le chaos le côté organique
presque
une espèce de vitalisme qui émerge de
ces images complètement artificiel
puisqu'il n'ya que des nombres il n'y a
aucune photographie qui est utilisé à la
base de ce travail je termine mon
doctorat en arts plastiques autour de
l'image de synthèse l'expression
d'accord pour éviter parce que le corps
c'est quand même le grand absent quand
on programme
et puis en terminant mon doctorat je me
dis hein mais quand même la lumière dans
tout ça j'avais explorer le pixel le
filaire l'affichage progressif la
stratification la matière et la lumière
si on enlève tout et si on ne garde que
la lumière qu'est ce qui pourrait être
intéressant alors si ça vous intéresse
j'ai un site où j'ai un article
d'habitude du pape entre deux heures sur
ce travail donc là je le fais un capteur
et en jouant alors je tâtonne ça c'est
mon logiciel j'ai travaillé avec des
oeuvres des étudiants en informatique
puisque pour programmer je peux
développer je peux bidouiller des choses
mais je suis pas capable de faire mon
propre logiciel mon propre environnement
de travail je travaille avec deux
étudiants en informatique qui me font un
environnement de travail je bidouille et
à un moment donné en désespoir de cause
est pas contente je joue à inverser un
par m alors que la la
la doc mais deviennent non c'est pas
possible c'est entre zéro et un jeu mais
- et qu'est ce que je trouve moins en
moins en moins à la tâche noire je me
dis ah c'est ça que je cherche ça
faisait deux ans que je tâtonnais un an
je travaille avec les étudiants voilà
j'ai mon idée
la lumière et l'obscurité avec un grand
challenge parce que quand on est en
images vidéo l'obscurité ou la pénombre
c'est pas terrible il faut du bon d'un
matériel et puis une fois que j'ai une
lumière noire gimeux fomo deuxième pôle
bipolarité le la lumière et l'obscurité
lumière bleue lumière rouge trois
lumières 2 obscures une claire en
fonction leur position dans l'espace
alors tout ça ça bouge vous avez en
ligne des exemples d'animation au bout
de vingt ans puisque ça c'est un projet
que je commence en l'an 2000 par un j'ai
fait un peu le tour des trois lumières
mais je me dis a ainsi changé la couleur
du fond alors là c'est comme si je
recommençais à 0
la couleur du fond ça fait des
sensations perceptive autour de la
couleur assez incroyable alors bon je
voulais faire du rouge je suis tombé
dans le rose lors aux mois en général
leur hozjan pas trop ça fais profil
jussiê à le rosé l'informatique
passionnant comme opposition et puis
j'ai repris un peu du rouge du côté de
l'agressivité parce que le rose peut
être dur mais il a quand même un côté
acidulé ou double en fait même si j'aime
beaucoup l'ambivalence et puis je
termine sur le projet pour lequel en
fait j'ai eu aussi ce désir de
travailler sur l'obscurité à la lumière
outre ronde qui est un projet interactif
donc la voyez l'écran au milieu le
public le participant j'ai fait
développé un capteur qui récupère le
mouvement de la tête
le but le image apparaît en périphérie
de vision
écran circulaire donc l'image tourne
autour du public du participant et en
fait mon idée c'est que dans le tweet et
la lumière c'est un grand stimulus
lumière de ce moment donc le public veut
regarder l'image et l'image esquive les
millimages joue à cache cache avec le
public le participant donc ça c'est le
cylindre temps que le public essaye de
regarder l'image ils n'y arrivent pas
puisque l'image et steve et refuse
d'être regardés on détruit quand on
cherche à voir et quand on ralentit
quand on a compris qu'on ne pouvait pas
voir eh ben mon ralenti on reste
immobile où on va lentement on chasse on
essaie d'apprivoiser et à ce moment là
l'image bien
plus on est en mouvement - envoi - on
bouge et plus l'image au coloré
j'ai bénéficié une
résidence où vous êtes quand même
pendant quatre ans j'ai aussi exposé là
bas c'est la grande messe de l'art
technologique à 15 trous où j'ai pu
aussi réalisé une
installation six écrans sur le côté ici
à une façade avec quatre autres écrans
ou là c'est ma pièce générative temps
réel j'en ai pas parlé mais qui évolue
dans le temps avec des paramètres et qui
de façon
infinie font varier les sensations de
couleur ainsi
[Applaudissements]